so I have sadly just terrible news for
you today the United States trajectory
of new cases since we got our first
hundred cases is the worst in the world
bar none
okay so look I'm gonna go through a few
bits of data with you today the way
things are going we are going to be in a
nightmarish dystopia that will make this
week and the hundreds of deaths this
week not seem that bad so before we look
at this I want to first update you on
the official numbers understand that
it's been an hour since I grabbed these
numbers so they've already changed
they've already gotten worse but as of
probably by the time you watch or listen
to this a few hours ago as of this
morning the United States had 68,000
official cases 68,000 official cases the
real number of cases of course is
probably between 4 and 20 times that so
we're looking at anywhere from you know
two hundred and seventy five thousand
cases 1.4 million cases we really don't
know because we aren't testing we are we
are backlogged on testing and a lot of
people aren't being tested at all so we
just don't know but the official case
number there it is in terms of the
states New York currently has just under
half of the whole country's cases other
hotspots are New Jersey California
seeing a big increase Washington State
has had a lot of cases they are getting
it under control there it's spiked
earlier in Washington as many of you
know and then you've got a bunch of
states right around 2000 official cases
Michigan Florida Illinois Massachusetts
Louisiana and then you've got another
tier in Georgia Texas Pennsylvania
Colorado
at every state has some cases at this
point now of course the United States is
a different sized country than others
were a large country geographically were
also a large country in terms of
population we've got about 340 million
people here with enough land area here
you essentially have states that both in
geographical size and in population can
be bigger than many individual European
countries so what we need to be looking
at just the case in on
don't tell us that much we need to look
at the trajectory how quickly our cases
and deaths increasing in the United
States when we look at that rate when we
look at how we are tracking one thing
that we look at is after we got our
first hundred cases meaning once you get
a hundred cases is when you know this is
going to be an issue and you've got to
start doing stuff we look at after a
hundred cases have been reached how
quickly have the numbers gone up on this
chart that we're putting up for you
which I will describe a steeper curve
means a faster increase in cases so when
you look I've highlighted certain lines
to make this easier to read cases in the
United States have increased more
quickly than they did in Spain and more
quickly than they did in Italy Italy is
one of the most disastrous and tragic
situations around the world our cases
are increasing more quickly than that
and since about day nineteen after
hitting 100 cases we even passed China's
level of increase which initially had
absolutely cartoonishly disastrous
numbers so the point is we started later
in that other countries started seeing
case growth sooner than the United
States in absolute terms in February
instead of in March but in terms of the
speed at which cases are increasing here
in the United States we are doing worse
than just about every country and the
implications are disastrous if this
doesn't change and remember 30 states
aren't doing a damn thing to make it
slow down in another 10 days we are
going to have an unconscionable number
of cases an insane number of people
hospitalized the medical system will be
overwhelmed deaths are going to
skyrocket and hospitals are actually
already overwhelmed
some of the stuff Trump is talking about
you know ad hoc FEMA facilities bringing
a hospital ship up to New York City it
takes weeks or longer to get that stuff
online so right now while we're working
on a vaccine that's a year away we're
testing large clinical trials looking at
anywhere from four to there's really 30
or 40 different possible treatments that
are being explored the only tool we
have right now is physical distancing
and staying the hell home and Donald
Trump is starting to talk about ending
it on April 12th and filling churches in
large parts of the country so just do
the math as to whether this makes sense
meanwhile Germany while dealing with
lots of cases they are keeping their
death rate very very low and when this
started and the death rate was low in
Germany we thought well Germany just
hasn't gotten that many cases yeah the
the more serious cases are going to
develop the death rate is going to go up
Germany now has nearly 40,000 confirmed
cases and only 222 deaths as of this
morning still tragic 222 deaths but it's
a death rate of about half of one
percent that's very good compared to
what we're seeing in a lot of other
countries the question is why one thing
is their medical system is not yet
overwhelmed number two they started
testing earlier so they have probably a
closer to accurate assessment of the
number of cases still not totally
accurate but closer than the United
States we know and doctor Isaac bogus
told us earlier this week the outcomes
are much better when the system is not
overwhelmed the earlier and the more
that you test so you can quarantine
people the better you're going to do in
terms of preventing that medical system
from becoming overwhelmed overwhelmed
this is the point of social distancing
this is the point of flattening the
curve given 100,000 cases in a month
versus 100,000 cases in six months you
prefer it in six months because it keeps
the hospital's less full and therefore
the outcomes are better meanwhile we
have a president who wants to go in the
other direction and let her rip on April
12th I'm getting now dozens of emails
daily from people in the Netherlands
saying we're fully shut down until I
think they said June 1 Canada saying we
you know even our briefings from Trudeau
he's by himself versus Trump still
talking about social distancing and up
on a dais with a crowd of people in a
room full of reporters people are
emailing me saying I'm so sorry David
that you're dealing with a country that
is doing seemingly the opposite of what
many other countries have figured out
it's it's very very bad let's take a
quick break after the break
we will talk about who do Americans
trust when it comes to the virus you
might be surprised or maybe not we'll
also talk about 5g conspiracy theories
exploding now that they can be
interlinked with coronavirus those
stories and more coming up right after
the break I'd love it if you checked out
a YouTube channel we're partnering with
their content is great and they're good
friends of the David Pakman show the
channel is called up flip and you can
get there at david pakman.com slash up
flip make sure you subscribe when you're
there if you own your own business if
you're thinking of starting one if
you're interested in entrepreneurship
and building companies as many of you
know I am I think you will love this
because every week up flip gives you
sort of an inside look at a successful
small business how did the entrepreneur
do it how was it built from the ground
up the stories are inspiring I always
love learning about how business owners
got to where they are and they share a
ton of wisdom about mistakes what they
learned really great insights and up
flip up loads new videos every Wednesday
featuring a totally new business check
it out at david pakman.com slash up flip
link is right down below underneath this
video subscribe to their channel and
click that Bell icon to get
notifications